nach innerparteilicher kritik als
fraktions und parteivorsitzende zurück
sie wolle damit die möglichkeit eröffnen
dass in beiden funktionen in geordneter
weise die nachfolge geregelt werden
können so nahles heute in einem
schreiben an die spd mitglieder
am montag werde es im parteivorstand
ihren rücktritt vom vorsitz und am
dienstag in der fraktion ihren rücksitz
rücktritt vom fraktionsvorsitz erklären
und das sind bislang die wichtigen
entwicklungen die uns erreicht hat
bereits am mittwoch gab es ja eine sehr
spannende fraktionssitzung und da konnte
man sehen dass ist möglicherweise nicht
so weitergeht andererseits es gab keinen
gegenkandidaten ich begrüße zu diesen
entwicklungen ganz herzlich bei mir
professor volker kronenberg von der
universität bonn professor kronberg wie
überraschend kam das jetzt heute für sie
dass es heute kam war eine überraschung
dass es in der kommenden woche sich so
entwickeln könnte damit konnte man
rechnen denn die wenn man die erklärung
von frau nahles vom heutigen vormittag
nimmt in geordneter weise die nachfolgen
da muss man sagen die hoffnung stirbt
zuletzt denn das was wir seit dem
tiefschlag der europawahl diesem
ergebnis erlebt haben war eine konfusion
in abläufen einer dissonanz
es war spürbar dass sie im grunde und
das ist das entscheidende das heft des
handelns nicht mehr in der hand hatte
bis hin zur organisatorischen fragen
eben der festsetzung wann will sie sich
bestätigen lassen im amt denn das ist ja
keine zufälligkeit als
fraktionsvorsitzende sie wollte
sozusagen diese offene machtfrage im
raum steht
sie wird ja ganz massiv in frage
gestellt nicht erst seit der europawahl
sondern ja schon seit wochen und monaten
sie wollte das natürlich rasch klären
warum um handlungsfähig zu sein nach
außen in der regierung das wurde
bestritten man hat ganz offen ihre
rivalen konkurrenten damit spekuliert
dass man dann im herbst nach den
landtagswahlen in ostdeutschland im
grunde sie beiseite räumen wollte könne
gehen musste sie entgegentreten das ist
ihr nicht wirklich gelungen die finanzen
überall
und damit hat sie jetzt im grunde auf
den letzten metern vor dieser wichtigen
woche die reißleine gezogen und hat das
heft des handelns in der hand behalten
es war erwartbar dass das ergebnis bei
der europawahl schlecht ausfallen würde
so schlecht damit hatte man im
willy-brandt-haus nicht gerechnet welche
auswirkungen hatte das noch für diese
entscheidung und den druck der jetzt
entstanden ist hat im grunde ich will
sagen einfach zu tage treten lassen dass
die partei zerrissen ist das hat kevin
kühn hat immer wieder der
juso-vorsitzende intoniert seit monaten
aber es ist für alle sichtbar in der
partei die wählerinnen und wähler die
bevölkerung es geht ja nicht nur um die
frage der themen hat man zu wenig jetzt
auf klima gesetzt und die junge
generation und die neuen medien das ist
das eine die viel grundlegendere frage
ist doch was will denn die spd und wohin
will sie will sie weiter
regierungsverantwortung tragen wie sie
in die opposition will sie im grunde in
neue koalition will sie nach links in
der mitte bleiben und mit wem dann
letztendlich auch das sind doch die
quälenden fragen seit vielen monaten
dieses vakuum musste irgendwann
aufplatzen und jetzt ist es da und wir
können nicht davon ausgehen dass in den
nächsten tagen oder gar wochen
irgendetwas kalkulierbar rational
geordnet laufen wird warum weil diese
fragen so grundlegend sind im grunde
steht zu erwarten dass sich die parteien
stück weit aus dem spiel nehmen wird ich
glaube nicht dass diese große koalition
im jahr 2019 wirklich bestand haben dazu
können wir auch gleich mit unserem
korrespondenten er als schärfer sprechen
ich frage mal nach ob die schalte steht
steht noch nicht dann hören wir auch die
neuesten entwicklungen aus berlin
was hat ist der partei bisher gebracht
andrea nahles übernahm nach martin
schultze nach der niederlage bei der
bundestagswahl und damit war viel
hoffnung verbunden ist das grundproblem
was die spd jetzt hat und zwar schon
vorher hatte denken wir an die abgänge
von kurt beck ist das ein thema was mit
dieser volkspartei spd einfach
zusammenhängt oder ist das ein
klassisches deutsches thema weil wir
gucken jetzt ja auch gleichzeitig auf
die cdu wo man hängt das zusammen
viel deutet es an es gibt natürlich ganz
viele faktoren die hier zusammenkommen
gibt eben nicht den
oder die 2 denn das könnte frau nahles
dann auch in den griff kriegen
erinnern wir uns im april 2018
angetreten und wenn wir die reden hören
einerseits verantwortung tragen dass
staatspolitische das war immer auch ein
charakteristikum einer volkspartei
volksparteien wollen gestalten wollen
regieren haben nicht die sehnsucht in
die opposition zu gehen dass das eine
auf bei anderen seite sie war immer eine
diskussionsfreudige und streit freudige
partei aber wir erleben doch seit
einigen jahren spätestens seit schröders
agenda-politik anderen mehr
das ist natürlich dieser riss in der
partei die unterschiedlichen strömungen
hat es immer gegeben links gegen rechts
verantwortung tragen und opposition dann
durch erstarken der linkspartei das im
grunde dieser riss bis heute eben nicht
geheilt werden konnte dass diese wunde
weiter schwert wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen andrea nahles ist seit vielen
jahren ich würde fast sagen jahrzehnten
in der partei groß geworden sie kennt
die partei wenn einer um es jetzt mal
positiv zu sagen hätte im grunde wissen
können wie man in der partei ist besser
machen kann
denn wer es sie gewesen wäre sie es
gewesen und sie hat immer wieder auch
versucht zu werben wie hat eine
organisationsreform mit ihrem
generalsekretär kriegen weil anderes
mehr ja angekündigt aber es ist
natürlich immer auch ein spagat
einerseits regierungsverantwortung zu
tragen hier aber auch zu liefern mit
kita gesetz und jetzt wieder mit mit mit
grundrente und anderem mehr es wurde ja
geliefert auch in den vorangegangenen
großen koalition unter merkel aber davon
hat die partei nicht profitieren in dem
maße in dem sie elektrorad eben
zurückgegangen ist ist natürlich
sozusagen die sache ist größer geworden
und die sehnsucht raus aus dieser
regierungsverantwortung wir haben es
eben mit diesen strömungen zu tun und
wie man da rauskommen will aus dem
dilemma das ist jetzt die grosse frage
fallen wer diese wären wir nach was in
berlin in diesen stunden so passiert
erhard scherfer ist uns direkt aus dem
hauptstadtstudio zugeschaltet mit diesem
brief an die mitglieder oder vermutlich
eine e mail war es ja vielleicht viel
mehr an die mitglieder ist es offenbar
geworden sie tritt zurückkehrt wir hören
viele gerüchte
was ist der letzte stand ja jetzt mal
schauen wann denn das ganze vonstatten
gehen soll und wie das ganze vonstatten
gehen soll es ist große unruhe ist es
natürlich ein
dabei in der sozialdemokratie die jetzt
sagen endlich das wollen wir ja schon
seit monaten sind es ja eben auch
angesprochen und bei einigen ist jetzt
auch schlicht und einfach durchaus
entsetzen da wenn die frage ist ja jetzt
tatsächlich wie es weitergeht einmal mit
der parteiführung es hat sich ja da
keiner recht stark gemacht die letzten
monate muss man ja fairerweise dazusagen
der brief die solidaritätserklärung der
stellvertretenden parteivorsitzenden der
dann gestern bekannt geworden ist es
auch sehr sehr spät gekommen die
diskussion über sie sie haben es mit
volker kronenberg besprochen ist sind
schon seit monaten sehr aktiv es gab in
den vergangenen tagen auch ganz
besonderes besondere ausreißer wenn ich
das mal so sagen darf also da hat es ja
auftritte gegeben auf der fraktionsebene
am vergangenen mittwoch die jenseits der
stilistischen zulässigkeit waren so
möchte ich mal formulieren also wenn
sich da ein bundestagsabgeordneter
hinstellt und sagt allein der
kindertraum spd vorsitzende zu werden
qualifizierte jemanden noch nicht für
das amt als partei- und
fraktionsvorsitzender dann ist das schon
ziemlich starker tobak auch wenn man
hier mutmaßen kann aus welcher richtung
das ganze dann natürlich kommt der
einzelnen abgeordneten haben wir ja
sogar gesehen also da ist eine menge
auch unterhalb der gürtellinie gespielt
worden gegen andrea nahles ist der druck
auf sie ist enorm gewesen in den
vergangenen monaten eigentlich sogar von
anfang an
das hat sie zwischenzeitlich mal gesagt
und dass er so stark war hätte sie
damals nicht gedacht oder war sie mal
gerade vielleicht ein viertel oder ein
halbes jahr im amt
das ganze hat sich jetzt verstärkt und
zwar massive wir gesehen haben es ist
gezweifelt worden in ihrer eignung und
eine große rolle wird wahrscheinlich
auch die fraktionssitzungen die sonder
fraktionssitzung am vergangenen mittwoch
gespielt haben als doch sehr viele
abgeordnete aus ihren wahlkreisen
berichtet haben und da gesagt haben wie
stark die stimmung eigentlich gegen
andrea nahles ist inzwischen und das hat
die natürlich dann wiederum auch
transportiert gegenüber der
noch partei- und fraktionsvorsitzenden
und das mag dann über den feiertag mit
etwas ruhe und distanzen zu diesem
ergebnis geführt haben dass wir jetzt
haben dass sich wie das ganze sich
abwickeln wird wie gesagt noch recht
nicht recht abzeichnet blicken wir noch
mal auf den mittwoch hat sie waren ja
live dabei dort auf der fraktionsebene
und haben schon ein bisschen von der
stimmung berichtet gleichzeitig hat sich
aber kein gegenkandidat gefunden bis zu
dem zeitpunkt oder keiner getraut oder
noch nicht aus der deckung gewagt
erzählt noch ein bisschen von diesem
stimmungsbild wie war da die gefühlslage
weil danach hieß es ja wenn sie dann
ohne gegenkandidaten schlechtes ergebnis
bekäme wer sie genau so beschädigt wie
wenn jemand sozusagen ihr amt übernehmen
oder ist überhaupt den gegenkandidaten
gebe
das war ein merkwürdiger tag also ist
begann ja also gegen 12 mit der einigen
sitzungen einiger landesgruppen und in
diesem landesgruppen ist offenbar schon
versucht worden den druck auf andrea
nahles sind wie stark zu vergrößern
hatte man den eindruck insbesondere die
nordrhein westfalen kam damit ernsten
und mit ernsten mienen aus ihrer
landesgruppen aus ihrer
landesgruppensitzung zurückhaben wenig
gesagt dazu bis gar nichts verlauten
lassen und dann habe ich ja die
gelegenheit gehabt mit dem vorsitzenden
der landesgruppe niedersachsen mit
johann saathoff ein interview zu führen
der uns da gesagt hat das war so gegen
halb zwölf der uns gesagt hat das wäre
auf jeden fall am kommenden dienstag
einen gegenkandidaten gegeben da sei er
sehr sicher dass es dazu komme und dann
ist sind diverse kandidaten die es in
den vergangenen tagen ja gegeben hat die
da gehandelt worden sind sind teilweise
offen gefragt worden in der
fraktionssitzung dann und einige haben
in dieser fraktionssitzungen gesagt nein
sie würden unter diesen bedingungen
nicht zur verfügung stehen sie würden
nicht gegen andrea nahles antreten
matthias miersch beispielsweise der
vorsitzender der parlamentarischen
linken in der spd bundestagsfraktion hat
gesagt dass er nicht antreten will
johann saathoff hat uns direkt im
interview gesagt dass er nicht antreten
will schon vorher martin schulz daher
auch immer wieder eine wichtige rolle
gespielt hat in diesem ganzen prozess
der sich jetzt einem ende entgegen neigt
hat der
eine aktive rolle zwei dementiert hat
was andere allerdings in der partei dann
doch ein klein wenig bezweifeln martin
schulz hat dann auch gesagt dass er
nicht antritt und achim post dessen name
der vorsitzende der landesgruppe
nordrhein westfalen dessen name auch
immer wieder gefallen ist in den
vergangenen tagen der ist auch gefragt
worden
von einem abgeordneten kollegen und er
hat zwar keine antwort gegeben aber
nicht auf diese frage ob er antreten
wird oder nicht
ja und da kann man schon ein bisschen
sehen dass er auch gemerkt ich taktiert
worden ist in den vergangenen tagen dass
man versucht hat dann wie gesagt auch im
vorfeld erst mal den druck so aufzubauen
dass möglicherweise andrea nahles von
sich aus schon zurückzieht schon in der
vergangenen woche eventuell und ja und
jetzt stehen wir da und schauen wir wie
es weitergeht
es scheint sich ein stück weit zu
konkretisieren dass beispielsweise oder
vermutlich malu dreyer den parteivorsitz
übernehmen könne interimistisch so lange
bis ist natürlich in auf einem neuen
parteitag eine neue vorsitzende oder ein
neuer vorsitzender gewählt ist dass es
quasi eine logische konsequenz oder wäre
das eine
theoretisch kommen ja alle
stellvertreter dafür einigermaßen in
frage wobei man beim halo 3 er
wahrscheinlich sagen muss ist ein
bisschen wahrscheinlichere variante weil
sieben immer ausgeschlossen hat glaube
ich parteivorsitzender zu werden dass
sie das jetzt übergangsweise übernimmt
sie ist ja nur eine politikerin die das
moderieren sehr sehr in der lage ist
also wieder ausgleichen kann jeder auch
kräfte zusammenführen kann die
möglicherweise den dieses verfahren dann
auch elegant abwickeln kann und ohne
weitere verletzungen die es ja ohnehin
gegeben hat in den vergangenen wochen
insofern ist das keine unwahrscheinliche
variante weil wie gesagt sie ich meine
auch immer ausgeschlossen hatte
parteivorsitzender zu werden
wer dann sich da jetzt stark macht das
mit neuer weiß wenn ja noch spannende
wochen werden denn es gibt ja so ein
paar die da durchaus geeignet werde
während die sich aber auch in der
vergangenen in den vergangenen wochen
vergleichsweise bedeckt gehalten haben
auch was die unterstützung für andrea
nahles angeht also ja interessant wir
bleiben am ball das ist jetzt ja auch
alles noch kaffeesatzleserei dafür ist
die nachricht auch einfach zu frisch am
heutigen nachmittag treffen sich
offensichtlich auch einige gremien oder
zumindest teile der parteiführung dann
sehen wir sicherlich weiter wir hören
uns später danken
professor kronberg wir haben ein
bisschen zeitdruck weil um 4 nach soll
der presseclub begehen noch einsatz dazu
was heißt das jetzt mutmaßlich für die
große koalition
na ja man hat ja ohnehin im herbst
vorgehabt eine zwischenbilanz zu ziehen
aber ob man bis dahin im grunde kommt
erfahrt gerade angedeutet dass sind
jetzt ganz aufregende tage und wochen
die vor der partei liegen einen aufruhr
ein machtvakuum bei diesem wichtigen
koalitionspartner wie will man denn da
zu wichtigen beschlüssen kommen
handlungsfähig seien auch mit blick auf
europas geht um personalfragen es geht
aber auch um inhaltliche fragen
klimaschutzgesetz anderes mehr
wenn eine partei so aufgewühlt ist und
im grunde gar nicht klären kann wie sind
die macht gewichte will man raus aus der
koalition will man drin bleiben will man
weiter bereit sein kompromisse zu
schließen oder will man im grunde sagen
wir ziehen die reißleine
wir stellen uns ja aber das ist
natürlich der punkt den die abgeordneten
dann letztlich doch scheuen werden wir
stellen uns jetzt den wählerinnen und
wählern
denn dann blickt man denken wir an
schulz der sich jetzt strahlt man
umfrage bei den umfragewerten 20,4 war
schon das historisch schlechteste und
jetzt hat man gerade europa gesehen es
geht noch weiter in den keller nur man
darf natürlich auch nicht nur an der
macht bleiben weil man das freut das
wird in der öffentlichkeit natürlich
auch schwer sein quadratur des kreises
nachfolgerin oder nachfolger von andrea
nahles mit sicherheit nicht zu beneiden
ich sage herzlichen dank für den moment
professor volker kronenberg sie bleiben
uns erhalten
werden nämlich spätestens um 13 uhr
wieder für sie da sein jetzt gehen wir
direkt ab zum presseclub nach köln um 13
uhr mein kollege klaus weidmann mit
einem aktuellen zum fall andrea nahles
[Musik]